on a personal note because you said
you've suffered from depression and
there's a lot of people that see
guidance on on this topic because it's
such a difficult one how were you able
to
when it was when it has struck you how
were you able to overcome it yeah I mean
this is
maybe too long an answer so I've
experienced it in different forms so it
was my I would say my depression has
almost always mostly taken the form of
anxiety
I didn't realize how anxious I was
I think until I was an adult so I was
always very functional
um I think you know all the positive
sides of suffering in that way
um I think I'm a little OCD as soon
until I mean this whole conversation is
hilarious because we're both suffering
to some level of anxiety psychology is
just laid out in front of us here it's a
giant mess it's kind of human it's great
is trying trying to organize hold on
like the Tom Waits song
um but then I I suffered from postpartum
depression after both of my daughters
after both pregnancies
um that was a very different experience
from anything I've ever experienced but
clearly it had a predisposition towards
you know suffering from something like
that
um anyway it really wasn't until I fully
recovered from the second experience of
postpartum depression that I realized
that I had been suffering on some level
my whole life and I think I always knew
I I thought of myself as a very
sensitive person an empathic person
um I mean I've been in therapy for 10
years
um
I knew I
had a lot of anxiety I would never have
denied that I had a lot of anxiety I
just didn't realize it crossed over into
a disorder really until I was an adult
and ended up taking
um Prozac I took an SSRI for postpartum
and
it was fascinating to me I ended up
interviewing my psychiatrist because I
was so fascinated in the whole thing
once I was on the other side of it just
what I had been through how different I
felt during that period of time and then
how quickly the medication made me feel
like myself again
I had come out the other side of the
experience of postpartum
um and was going to start tapering off
the medication and in this window where
I no longer had postpartum depression
um
and hadn't yet gone off the SSRI
I realized
that life was not only a lot easier than
when I had postpartum but it was easier
than it had ever been
and it took
taking all of that anxiety away to
recognize how much I had been
grappling with it my entire life
and it first started coming in the form
of realizations like
oh is this how other people yeah is this
how other people feel is this how that
like the things that I just always
thought of myself I'm really sensitive I
I'm an introvert I need a lot of time to
myself and all of these things that I
felt like
um I mean it's always very high
functioning
um and in some ways you know I was a
professional dancer and I think that was
the type of therapy for me there was the
obsessing over
um
the training and dancing nine hours a
day and all of that I now look back on
and see how much that was
um therapeutic for me
um and then I was kind of treating
something but uh yeah it was so it was
just this experience of
um
treating an anxiety disorder that caused
me to realize that I had one I didn't
know I could feel the way I felt
after taking Prozac and I became very
interested in I mean I I was already
working with neuroscientists I was
always already interested in
Consciousness in the brain and
um it just you know this kind of rattled
other intuitions for me in terms of how
our child how our childhoods shape who
we become
um because I had been convinced my my
father was
my my father was a complicated person as
you said before
that's what I was going to say again
I mean so he he was not diagnosed I
think he was born I think he had
borderline personality disorder and was
emotionally abusive and I thought that
all of the ways I experienced the world
and all of my anxiety and my
sensitivities
um
I thought almost all of that if not all
of that was because of these experiences
I had growing up and Trauma that I
experienced as a child and obviously
those things play a part but what I
realized
um after going through postpartum and
then the thing that was extremely
informative to me was having my own
children
um
because they were basically living my
dream childhood they had none of the
things that I thought were the cause of
the psychological suffering that I
experienced
um there was none of that and they have
a lot of the same
um they struggle with a lot of the same
anxiety and panic attacks and what I
realized was
how much were kind of Born Into the
world with these things that we that we
struggle with and with our strengths and
with all of that and of course then if
you have an abusive childhood if you're
if you're someone who
tends to be anxious and sensitive and
empathic and then you're you're born
into an abusive situation that's obvious
terrible combination
but I never acknowledged or realized how
strong just the the genetics and the
wiring
played where's the line between you kind
of accepting the challenges you're born
with and this is what life will be
versus then figuring out that life can
be somehow different I think they're
part of the same process and I think
it's kind of necessary to accept
what you're experiencing and what the
situation is and
how you feel and the types of
um
thoughts and patterns you tend toward in
order to make whatever changes can be
made so I do think it's kind of part of
the same process could life have been
any different I mean do you regret
certain aspects of the decisions made
not by you I mean you know it depends
depends on what level we're talking I
think you know at a fundamental level I
I don't believe anything could be
different are you able to think about at
that level about your own life sure and
that's actually that's part of what I
was when I wanted to kind of talk a
little bit about the
um levels of usefulness of being aware
of these different Illusions because I
would say most of the time in our daily
lives
um the types of illusions that I'm
interested in in shaking up are not
useful to remind ourselves of most of
the time
I really think there are different
levels of usefulness to
thinking about and reminding ourselves
of the places where we have false
intuitions and so I I often use
um
the analogy of living on a sphere
um so
it still feels to most of us most of the
time I mean our intuitive sense we're
not thinking about whether the the Earth
is flat or a sphere but we behave as if
it's flat and that makes the most sense
and
um it would be exhausting to keep
reminding ourselves as we walk down the
street like it feels flat but it's not
flat like there's just no reason to do
it's not useful in in that moment um if
you're building a house you can build it
as if the world is flat
um
and but you know of course so they're so
their psychological reasons to bring it
into view and maybe even spiritual
reasons to bring an interview and then
there's just like usefulness so if
you're building a rocket to the moon you
better understand
the geometry of the earth
um even if you're flying an airplane if
you're an airplane pilot you have you
have to be aware of the truth of our
situation
um and then I think there are other
places where it's interesting
to remind ourselves is where I I start
out my book
um
just
as a way to inspire awe and to get
yourself out of your everyday life and
see the big picture which can be
um just a relief but also helps you feel
more connected to the universe into
something larger than ourselves and so I
see these intuitions
um reminding ourselves that these
intuitions are Illusions in the same way
that most of the time they're not useful
they are useful if we want to think
about a science of Consciousness
um they're useful for a whole range of
neuroscientific studies and I think they
can be incredibly useful in the same way
that lying on the ground and feeling the
gravity pushing you against a sphere and
realizing you're floating in the middle
of outer space
it gives me the same feeling to realize
and so
I have I mean there's so many levels to
it but if I'm thinking about difficult
things that I've experienced
um different traumas in my life when I
take a step back and kind of get this
bird's eye view of
kind of the mystery of this unfolding of
the universe and the fact that
um it happened the way it happened and
whether it could have happened another
way or there's no going back that is
that's the way it unfolded and being
able to surrender to that I think
um is very psychologically healthy and
and prevents us from I mean I think
regret is one of the most toxic Loops we
can get into so this is this is a path
to acceptance oh absolutely yeah because
Free Will I mean I think part of what is
the function of the experience of it is
is learning um I mean I think we can
still learn without being under the
illusion that we that we have free will
so for some people depression
can destroy them so how did how how can
you think about
avoiding yeah yeah so one so I didn't
totally answer your question first is um
therapy
ways that I have
have worked through anxiety and
depression so you like you're uh
uh an introvert and a deeply
intellectual person therapy works for
you
to a point
it was very helpful
um I mean I think talk therapy is one
tool and can be helpful
for I mean it depends on the therapist
depends on the type of therapy but I I
found it
to be one piece and probably not the
biggest piece actually
um but I think
Medicare I wish I had discovered
medication sooner that would have made a
big difference in my life even just
intellectually to realize that oh
like I'm not life was a lot harder than
it needed to be yeah and it wasn't about
keeping everything just so
um you know there's another state my
brain can be in where I don't have to
work so hard to be okay
um meditation was probably the most
meditation and psychedelic
experiences were probably the most
transformative
um
but you know a lot of these things don't
you know I'm I'm lucky that I didn't my
my anxiety and depression never really
got in the way of my living my life of
enjoying my life I mean there were
struggles that made life harder for me
um
but you know something like treatment
resistant depression
or severe PTSD
um these are things that
you know at this point in time you know
based on my understanding I think once
you've tried and and the truth is that
meditation is not is often not helpful
for those things it can actually
exacerbate them
um and the most promising thing that I
have seen is this Research into
psychedelic therapy assisted psychedelic